We're asked to move the
orange dot to negative 0.6
on the number line.
So the dot right now is at 0.
And let's see,
this is negative 2.
This is positive 2.
So each of these big
slashes look like it's 1.
So this would be
negative 1, negative 2.
This right over here
would be negative 0.5.
So we're going to
go a little bit more
negative than negative 0.5.
That would be negative 0.6.
We want to go another tenth.
And so that looks right
at about negative 0.6.
Let's do a couple more of these.
Move the orange dot to
1.9 on the number line.
So it seems like we
have the same scale
as in the previous example.
This gets us to 1.
In fact, this is 0.5, 1, 1.5.
And 1.9 is only going to
be a tenth less than 2.
So it's going to be--
let's see, that's 2,
so a tenth less than that.
And I'm assuming that it's
locking us to the tenths.
And it looks like it is, so
that looks pretty close to 1.9.
Let's do one more of these.
Move the orange dot to
0.5 on the number line.
Well, once again, we
have the same scale.
It's important to
always check the scale.
And this right over here is 1.
So 0.5 would be halfway, so
that little small mark right
over there.